Let us begin with our prayer. Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God
to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy
of fulfilling the purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate
heart of my mother Mary and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live,
pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings,
wants or desires and may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure and that I remain so docile to the movement of
your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers. Amen. I want to begin in
March 14 1926 and this is a lovely message in which the Lord is telling us that we are the only
creatures he has made with a speaking faculty and he wants us to speak on behalf of all of his creation
and therefore our rounds are terribly important. Louisa said I continue to dissolve myself in the
holy divine will. I would like to embrace everything and everyone to be able to bring everything to my
God as my own things. See the Lord has given us everything so we want to give him back everything
but if we treat them as our own things we will have much greater input into the giving and I think
that's terribly important and we will have much greater motivation in actually doing it. I've sometimes
heard people saying oh I have to do my rounds you know I have to do my rounds. Well if everything
God has created is your own thing you wouldn't say that. Not at all. You'd be delighted to
give your own things to God and to give it to him with glory and praise. So that's where Louisa
actually realizes that everything is given to her. They were given to me by him as gifts in order to
give him for each created thing a little word of love a thank you I bless you and I adore you.
The beautiful thing is that we're being asked to speak up for all those millions of galaxies out
there in the universe. To speak up for the sun, to speak up for the moon, to speak up for the trees
and all the vegetation on the earth to speak up for the mountains. They can't speak for themselves
but when they hear us speaking up for them they will realize that we are Romans 829 people
that is the sons of God they were looking for. So Jesus came out from within my interior which
of course means that the kingdom of God is there. That's Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16
and he called the whole of creation in order to place it on my lap to give it to me as a gift.
She had perceived that already that it was given to her as a gift and with tenderness all of love
he said to me my daughter it's all yours. I think we need to take that one on board that really is
all ours. For one who must live in my will now it's one thing to say prayers in the divine will
it's quite another matter altogether to live in the divine will. For one who must live in my will
everything which came out of my will and which my will preserves and possesses must be fully
hers by right. Now the divine will is in all of creation and therefore all of creation is given to
us by gift and the Lord wants us to speak the word of gratitude and thanks on their behalf.
Now it was my omnipotent Fiat that extended the heavens and started them with stars that's Genesis
chapter 1. My Fiat called the light to life. Fiat looks let there be light and created the sun
as well as all the other created things and my Fiat remained inside the creation as triumphant
dominating and preserving life. In other words they didn't have free will to go against the will
of God. The will of God remained inside of them preserving them as they were created.
Now one who has won the divine will notice the expression won the divine will.
We're going to see as we go along these messages tonight that the whole process of entering into
the divine will and winning over the divine will is a long journey and most of us experience it
as a long journey and you think you're in the divine will all the time and in a sense you are
but there are deeper and deeper and deeper and deeper depths to go into it. For one who has won
the divine will and you remember a few lessons ago that Louisa was asked finally in volume 18
to lay her will on the altar of God as blessed mother had done from the first moment of her
conception but this was volume 18 that was a long journey. So for one who has won the divine will
has won the whole of creation as well because the divine will is in the whole of creation and you've
won even God himself. Therefore year the Romans 819 people the sons of God that the whole of creation
is looking for more so since the creation is mute for its creator that is Sam 19 verses one to four
they have no voice and yet they are heard throughout the whole universe. So the whole of creation is
mute and I made it mute because the one to whom I was to give it that's us and who was to live in
my will would herself have speech in all created things. In other words we are the voice of all
creatures giving praise to God. There's something very astounding about that
that the trees are waiting for us to praise God. All the little creatures on the earth are waiting
for us to praise God. I think it's wonderful. So the person to whom the divine will was going
to be given would have speech and therefore we would become the speaking creation. So you will be
the voice of the heavens listen to the words I think it's incredible. Imagine me being the voice
of the Milky Way giving thanks to God and I so small that I couldn't possibly imagine the size of it
and that's only one tiny speck of the universe. You will be the voice of the heavens. This is number
one and echoing from one to another it will make your word heard which resounding through the whole
celestial sphere will say I love you. I glorify you. I adore my creator. So we put the sound into
creation and the Lord says he will bounce it off all the galaxies and all the stars. That's an
incredible thing. Wouldn't it be wonderful to be able to illustrate that. You will be the voice of
each star. You will be the voice of the sun. You will be the voice of the wind. You will be the
voice of the thunder. You will be the voice of the sea. I'm repeating it to make sure we get the
message. You will be the voice of plants. You will be the voice of the mountains of everything
repeating continuously. I love you. I bless you. I adore you. I glorify you. I thank the one who
created us. Oh how beautiful will be the voice of the newborn in my will of the little daughter of
my volition in all things. Now from the time I started speaking on the volumes of Louisa I've
called that putting my signature on everything that God has done. And so the whole of creation
will see Francis's signature on it which I think is very special for me. I don't know about you.
So he wants us to speak on behalf of all of creation and he wants all of creation to pick it up
so that they will proclaim but we will have given them the words. And they've never offended against
the divine will because the divine will didn't give them the freedom to do that. And so when we
express on behalf of creation this praise and thanksgiving and glory then we are actually doing
something quite incredible what they would actually want us to do but they can tell us to do it.
So I will render the whole of creation speaking he said through you and creation will be more
beautiful that if I had given it the use of the word I love you so much that I want to hear your
voice in the word. I love you so much that I want to hear your voice in the sun loving adoring and
glorifying. I want to hear your voice in the celestial spheres. I want to hear your voice in
the murmuring of the sea in the darting of the fish in the bird that sings and warbles in the land
that bleats in the turtle of that moans. I want to hear you everywhere. So your voice literally
goes through the entire universe and all the dwellers of heaven actually hear your voice being
picked up by all of these different areas of creation. It's a magnificent picture. I would not
be content Jesus said if in all things in which my will has first place I did not hear the voice
of my little newborn who rendering the whole of creation a speaking creation gives me love for love
glory and adoration for each thing created by me so we return to God the glory that is actually
due to him at the level at which he is due as well. Therefore my daughter be attentive I've given you
much and much do I want now Luke 1248 says to him who has been given much much will be expected so
a lot of praise and thanksgiving is expected from us in the divine will your mission is great it is
the life of my will that must be carried out in you which embraces everything and possesses everything
that's a wonderful message so Louisa said after this I was thinking how can I do all that blessed
Jesus tells me being present in all things having one act for everything that the supreme volition
does you see that's our question as if it were to be my echo and I was to be the echo of the supreme
will since I'm only the new born in the divine will so I want to give you for newborn in the divine
will I want to give you one Peter two verses two to five and verses nine to 12 where he says we are
newborn I should at least grow up a little bit Louisa said let me be able to diffuse myself a little
more as best I can in all created things as my beloved Jesus wants now while I was thinking about
this he came out from within my interior and he told me my daughter don't be surprised if I tell
you that you're the newborn of my will you must realize that my immaculate mother herself is the
newborn of my will because in comparing what the creator is and what the creature can be and can
take from God she's just a little newborn in other words by comparison with the creature the creature
is nothing and because she was the newborn of my will she was formed in the likeness of her
creator that's Romans 829 and also Genesis 127 and could be queen of all creation and as queen
she dominated everything and her echo ran well in the echo of the divine will so Louisa is the
newborn in the divine will she thinks you can't do this because she's so new and so tiny and then
Jesus explains that the blessed mother is also newborn and all of us are newborn in other words
we have to be reborn at every second and therefore everything is fresh and new so she
dominated everything in other words she could do all of these acts and give glory to God and not
only the celestial sovereign lady but all the saints the angels and the blessed can be called
newborn in the eternal volition and what Jesus is going to say now is some people wait until death
to be reborn into the divine will because in death you automatically go into the divine will if you
don't you're lost eternally but then in the next paragraph he's going to tell us that the real
blessing is to rebear reborn into the divine will in time during your lifetime so this that's where
he's going with this in fact as soon as the soul leaves her mortal body she's reborn into my will
that's in death and if she's not reborn in it not only can she not enter the celestial fatherland
she can't even be saved so outside of the divine will on the other side it's either heaven or hell
because no one enters the eternal glory if one is not a birth from my will that's why in the divine
will we do a lot of intercession for souls the way I put it is to get them across safely
to get them into the kingdom of God safely and you know when you see the amount of apostasy and
troubled it in the world today an extraordinary amount of intercession needs to be done so in this
new paragraph then Jesus is going to say the privilege that you have in being reborn into the
divine will in time however Jesus said I must tell you of the great difference that exists
between one who is the newborn of the supreme will in time that is in their own lifetime
and those who are reborn at the thresholds of eternity that is in death
one example is my queen mother who was reborn of the divine will in time or in her lifetime
and because she was newly born she had the power to make her creation to send upon the earth
and while he was still immense she made him become little within her maternal womb
to clothe him with her own nature and to offer him as the savior of the human generations
so because she was living in the divine will because the divine will was the dominator of her
entire being then this extraordinary event could actually take place by being newly born
she formed great seas of grace light sanctity and divine knowledge they always use the word
science for some reason because nowadays we have a different meaning to the word science
in which to contain the one that who had created her so she needed all of these extraordinary
seas of grace and light and beauty and sanctity and knowledge to be able to contain this mystery
within her and so by the power of the life of the supreme will which she possessed she was able
to do everything and to infiltrate everything now notice it's because the divine will is fully
dominant in her she is completely surrendered to the divine will because we've heard over and over
and over again it's the divine will that does it in us that's how it can be done God himself could
not deny what this celestial creature was asking for now we've illustrated that many times in in
these writings padre pio was asked why was it that the lord worked so many miracles through him
and he said I deny him nothing and he denies me nothing so since our blessed mother is so completely
surrendered to the divine will of course the lord would deny her nothing it's actually quite
important to know that if you are praying something according to the divine will
so he couldn't he couldn't deny her anything because it was his own will that was asking
that's where the power in prayer really comes from that we were given the the privilege
to enunciate or name what God actually wants to do and so he couldn't deny his own will
he could not and he should not of course so one who is newly born in my will in their lifetime
a form sees of grace during the time of the exile that is during your lifetime so you see we have to
keep on expanding and growing and letting the grace and the light and the beauty and the sanctity and
the knowledge of God increase in us continuously that it makes it more possible for us to surrender
to the lord at a deeper level and for him to give himself to us at a deeper level as well so it is
necessary for this action to take place all of which takes time of course so since he's forming
these seas of grace during the exile that is during her lifetime so when it comes to her death her
departing from the earth this soul carries with herself all the seas of the goods which the divine
will possesses and therefore she carries with her god himself limited and plain English the soul
living in the divine will brings god to heaven can you imagine the celebration can you imagine
the welcome it is totally beyond our capacity to understand because the vast majority who die
jesus going to explain this now they have to find god on the other side whereas the person
living in the divine will brings god with them and that's why the assumption of our blessed mother was
such a wonderful occasion the first time a person left the earth carrying god with her to glory
so let's let's read that again i think that's wonderful so when this soul departs from the
earth she carries with herself all the seas of the goods which the divine will possess us and therefore
she carries a god himself with her to bring the divine will from the exile to bring god
who reigns in heaven that is a portent a portent is assigned way beyond miracles
that's a portent he said you yourself cannot understand clearly the great goods the tragedies
of one who is newly born in my will in their lifetime therefore of all that i tell you
you can do everything more so since my will itself will do it that is the secret whatever god
asks of us we just say yes lord i want you to do that within me because he is the only one who can do it
so the divine will itself accomplishes the act as though identified with your little being
now can you imagine i know you can't the immensity of the omnipotent god and the nothingness of our
being and yet he somehow manages to identify it's utterly amazing on the other hand for one
who is reborn in my will only on departing from the earth that is in death it is the divine will
that makes this soul find its amendses to make the soul be reborn in it so the rebirth is after death
it is god that makes himself found by her that's a different subject altogether
what a difference between the two therefore a greater grace i could not give you than making
you the newborn in my will and if you love to grow let my will alone grow and so if the divine will
is the thing that's growing in us everything's fine it's the most wonderful message that we need
to give a lot of attention to so let's come to march the 19th 1926 and we have to just realize that
the divine willy eclipses everything even creation and redemption and absolutely everything we have
to understand just that when we're talking about divine will we're talking about the essence of god
louisa is almost afraid to write this message and she says i write this only to obey i was thinking
to myself my beloved jesus tells me many times that i must be the copy of our celestial mother
and therefore to embrace everything and to make up for all to be able to impotrate for the longed
for fear just as she impotrated for the longed for redemption but how can i do this she was holy
she was conceived without original sin i on the other hand i'm one of the littlest and poorest
creatures conceived with original sin like all the children of adam full of miseries and weaknesses
this is a very good paragraph because it picks up the questions that people out there have about
the divine will since the question is in the first paragraph the answer comes afterwards
which is terribly important so how then shall i be able to follow the flights of the sovereign
lady in the divine volition in order to impotrate upon the earth the so longed for fiat
which my sweet jesus wants to reign while i was thinking of this jesus came out from within my
interior and clasping me tightly in his arms we would say giving her a big hug
said my daughter my mother was conceived without original sin so that she might be able to impotrate
the longed for redeemer in other words as a creature we can only do what god enables us to do
and he's now going to say that when a person is called to a very special role that all the graces
and gifts needed for that role are actually given so my mother was conceived without original sin
so that she might be able to impotrate the longed for redeemer because it was right and just and
proper that not even the seed of guilt would ever have existence in the one who was to be my mother
because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god hebrews 1214 she was to be the
noblest the holiest of all creatures that wonderful or as the poet said our tainted nature solitary
boast she was to be the noblest and the holiest of all creatures but of a divine nobility and of a
holiness all similar to her creator in other words there were holy people before her there were saints
before her but not at the level that she was at because she was living at the divine will level
that's the highest level that you can actually go to all the other saints were at the ordinary
level there were saints but at a different level that's like saying i have done a past exam and
done very well and my friend has done an honors exam and it's got an a there's actually a big
difference a very poor illustration but you get the idea so she had a divine nobility and a holiness
all similar to her creator that he might find in her so much grace and the capacity as to be able
to receive the holy of holies now notice the word capacity this is a very important word
we're very tiny little nothings in ourselves but our capacity for god is utterly reduced
according to the sinfulness of the creature and according to our attachment to sins and the damage
that is done by sin and all the rest of us and in our journey into the depths of the divine will
the lord has to increase our capacity little by little as we let go of the things that we must
dump anyway and allow him to heal and to purify and sanctify and increase our capacity to receive
more of him so that we can surrender more and have more purification and to receive more capacity
until the end we can actually really receive him in so far as a creature can it's a huge journey
and there are surrenders all along the way so you will know that you are moving in the divine will
if you are aware of the fact that there are surrenders in other words that i have to
let something go now that last year was okay because at the capacity i was at last year
it was acceptable or tolerable but where i am now and wanting to surrender at a much deeper level
that would have to go so that the floodgates of divine grace can open so she had to be literally
flooded with grace we have a lovely thing that we say in latin that she was maria maria
a sea of grace and her name was maria the sea of grace okay so look at what jesus says here
she had to be able to conceive the holy of holies now the holy of holies was the place
where the ark of the covenant was and so if she was to conceive the holy of holiness this is jesus
himself saying that our best mother was the ark of the covenant the container of the divine word
okay the eternal word is the holy of holies you see that there and so the reference there is to
the ark of the covenant because in the ark of the covenant was a container and because it its
treasures were so incredible it had to be overlaid in gold representing god and inside of the ark of
the covenant they had the two tablets of stone on which the divine word was carved there was the jar
of manna representing the bread of god the word of god the bread of god and there was the priestly
sign also the rod that budded and so the signs inside of the ark of the covenant were word bread
and priest and the person whom mary conceived in her womb was he who is word bread and priest
divine word divine bread divine priest and so she's the ark of the covenant it's lovely the way he just
gives you that just a few words so he's going to illustrate this now what he's trying to say to her
in the next paragraph in other words he says if you've got a wonderful treasure you're going to put it
in some very expensive container but if the thing you have isn't really worth much you won't have a
wonderful container so for a blessed mother to take to be able to hold the presence of the holy of
holies she had to be superlative in grace okay so let's look at this Jesus said many times creatures
do this as well when having to keep precious things of great value they prepare a most clear
vase now we would say crystal and the vase would have a value equivalent to the precious things that
are in them you see the amount of grace that had to be given to mary to contain the wonder of the
holy of holies on the other hand if those are ordinary things and of little value they prepare
vases of clay and a very little value and nor did they have the care of keeping them under lock and
key as they do with the most clear vase and of course the arc of the covenant was kept in the
holy of holies that was absolutely untouchable by even the priests only the high priests could go
near it once a year so from the preciousness of the vase and from the way it is kept one can know
whether the things contained in it are precious and of great value that's the point he's making
so if you look at the sheer extraordinary level of grace that was given to blessed mother
then you know the preciousness of what she had within her and of course he's going to go on and
say the same thing to louisa in the next paragraph so now since i was to receive her blood in order
to be conceived in her womb it was right that both soul and body be most clear now the clear he's
talking about the divine will is light and the clearest way that we can get to light in a material
things to have crystal and we in ireland know the the value of waterford crystal absolutely magnificent
and this is what he's saying that the container itself tells you how precious it is and that she
be enriched with all possible imaginable graces privileges and prerogatives that god can give and
that the creature can receive as philippians 419 that god would enrich you as only god could
okay so now he has to explain to louisa in the next paragraph that according to her capacity
according to her calling the same thing is done in other words it's the same plan
now my daughter if all this happened to my dear mother because she was to make the
longed for redeemer descent upon the earth so you also since i've chosen you for the longed for
fiat longed for by heaven and by earth longed for with great love and yearning by the very divinity
even more longed for by god rather than men i had to give you so much grace so as not to place the
knowledge pertaining to my will in a corrupted soul and body very important Hebrews 1214 nothing
unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god and the divine will is the essence of god
so he's going to explain what exactly he had to do with louisa because after all she was born with
original sin so and not only he said did i have to give you the knowledge but i had to give you the
very life of my will he had to experience it which it was to form and carry out within you in other
words everything you wanted to give to us he had to give to her in fullness because she was the one
opening the new era therefore making use of its omnipotent understood power even though it did not
exempt you from original sin with its power the divine will repressed the inclination to sin
and stood firm over it now you know what he did in louisa the divine will repressed the inclination
to sin and stood firm over it that it might not produce its corrupted effects so in you my will
keeps original sin crushed and without life that's an absolutely extraordinarily important
answer to be able to give to people who ask you know how come you you compare louisa with the blessed
mother when the blessed mother was without sin so that explains when you go back to the early
volumes and you find louisa suffering incredibly the corruption of sin doesn't rare its ugly head
this was right jesus said it was necessary for louisa no it was necessary for the nobility
and the decorum and the sanctity of the supreme will now earlier he said two paragraphs back he
said that all the gifts and grace and everything that was given to our blessed mother it was to do
with the fact that she was going to carry the holy of holies within her everything that's given to
louisa it's because she is to carry the divine will within her everything that the lord has to give
to you and me it's because we will carry the divine will to whatever level we will carry it
and i think it will be carried at all kinds of levels by all kinds of people
if any effects which are not good were present in you my will would find shadows and fogs and would
not be able to spread its rays of truth like the sun in its full midday in other words it would
meet opposition and if the divine will met opposition in louisa what he planned to do in her and through
her actually just wouldn't happen so and even less would the divine will form in you the center
of the carrying out of its divine life because my will is so clear now you know that since volume
11 the divine will has been called light because god is light one john one five
and it's so clear our our faults and miseries would would smudge it
the divine will is so clear and so holy that it cannot be nor adapt itself to living together
with the slightest spot that is why as we go along in our journey in the divine will the lord
taps you on the shoulder and indicates that something else has to go something else has to go
something else has to go that is if you want the fullness of union with him
you can't have him and little bits of selfishness you can't have him and little bits of self interest
that they don't go together at all you can't have him and little bits of worldliness
so i want to give you a song of songs four seven for this piece here i want to give you a fusions
five twenty seven and i want to give you a Hebrews nine fourteen that is we can't have even the slightest
spot he's looking for that crystal clear diamond that his light can come through in all its glory
so louise's reaction to this was to tremble i'm not surprised and she said Jesus what are you
saying his whole days actually possible yet i feel so miserable and little as to feel the need of
you of your assistance and of your presence to be able to continue to live now louise is saying
something very important there and that is that as you go along this journey you begin to realize
that if the lord doesn't support you in every possible way at every possible instant of life
you couldn't do it so i just say to him lord i surrender completely every nano second just for
a second then you bring me to the next second and then you bring me to the next one then you bring
me to the next one we need him absolutely we need his assistance for the way we think and the way we
decide and the way we reason we need his assistance to deal with our motivation our memories absolutely
everything because by the time you become an adult you're a complicated mess and the lord has to get
through that forest to try and seek and he have a clearing that he can work with and then he clears
the forest bit by bit as he goes along and louise continues you know to what a pitiful state i
reduce myself when you deprive me of yourself in other words if you leave me at all don't expect
all this wonderful stuff i couldn't do it it's wonderful that's your john 15 5 where jesus said
without me you can do nothing okay and louise is here saying that's the philippians 4 13 that i can
do all things in christ who gives me the strength but without him nothing nothing nothing so jesus
interrupted me and said my daughter don't be surprised it is the sanctity of my will that requires it
jesus sanctity of the divine will requires us to let go of all the unholyness that requires it
what this is about is the greatest thing that exists in heaven and on earth the greatest thing
that exists in heaven on earth is the divine will if in redemption i came to save man now it is about
rescuing my will in the creatures now i think it's very interesting because the very fact that we live
at all the divine will is in us we couldn't exist without the divine will the divine will is enabling
me to speak and you to listen and yet the divine will has to be rescued in us because the human
will is holding it down and the human will is holding it unable to have its freedom and to have
its reign so rescuing means that the human will has got to be dealt with notice the human will is
the enemy here the human will has to be dealt with to free the divine will i think that's incredible
because go back to exodus and the lord had to rescue his people out of egypt and now he's having
to rescue his own divine will inside of us it's fascinating so if in redemption i came to save man
now it was about rescuing my will in the creatures and therefore one making known the purpose of
creation and of redemption and two making known the goods which my will wants to give at the life
that it wants to form within each creature and the rights that befit the divine will these are the
things he wants to make known therefore placing a divine will in safety in the midst of creatures
is the greatest thing so what he's trying to do in louisa is get to the point where the divine will
is actually safe inside of her it's not going to be abused and he has to be very tentative with you
and me the can't trust us i think as much as he can trust louisa that the divine will will be able
to safely reign in us that we will not abuse it and we will not rebel against it and we will not
put it back into prison again i think we walk with the lord a very very long time before he actually
trusts us we can trust him but i don't think he can trust us because human nature is so prone to
falling and you see the gift that was given to louisa is not given to us that her original sin
is kept crushed and without life unfortunately original sin is alive and well in us so therefore
he said placing a divine will in safety in the midst of creatures is the greatest thing and my will
known and reigning will surpass the fruits of creation and redemption in other words when the
lord achieves his purpose in us he will have absolutely extraordinary results it will be the
crowning of my works and the triumph of our works and if my will is not known loved and fulfilled
neither creation nor redemption will obtain their full purpose and their complete fruit
so nothing is finished until everything is finished creation and redemption came out from within the
omnipotent fiat and so that our glory may be complete and the creature may receive all the effects and
the goods which they contain everything must return into our will everything came out of the divine
will everything must return to it this is the circle of love that all creation came out with
the love of god and that love must go back to god and until the love goes back to god the whole
process is not complete and so the divine will wants to triumph in us so that it can in fact go
back to god now who can say how my poor mind swam in the immensity of the eternal will and what i
understood louisa said but the point that impressed me the most was that the fiat was to surpass even
the good of redemption of all that was said one thing really clicked with her okay with the addition
of a terrible reluctance to manifest what was written above for fear that obedience would impose
on me to write oh how i would have wanted to keep silent but the fiat won't let me and one cannot
argue with the fiat now i love her saying this because you will know if you really are in the
divine will because when the lord wants something he won't let you off the hook our job is to surrender
and that's why i keep saying to people not my will but die and be done lord not my will but
die and be done we have to get really absolutely exercised in that okay just like tonight when i
wanted to come on early to greet everybody before the rosary i get a phone call you know and it
distracts you so not my will but die and be done lord so we continue then my sweet jesus always kind
came back and told me my daughter it's necessary that you manifest this in other words the divine
will is imposing itself my daughter it's necessary that you manifest this you have to do it for the
decorum and the sanctity which befit the divine will everything is about the divine will not about
us it's all about him do you think that all the crafting i've done in your soul for 40 years and
more has been only for you and for the love that i have and do have for you the lord wouldn't go to
all that trouble just to bring an individual to sanctity because bringing us to sanctity is actually
not the issue in divine will it's completing the divine plan that's the issue and you leave your
sanctity to the lord whatever he wants and that's the wonderful thing in the divine will you forget
yourself altogether and get on with what god wants and oh he said it's not just for you it has been
above all for the decorum of that which befit it my will so that in coming to reign in you i would
find my crafting my incessant prayers inviting it to come now notice it's all done by him even though
we think we're doing it i would find the throne of my works and of my pains on which it might dominate
and form its dwelling i would find the light of its very knowledge so that it might find in you its
honors and the very divine glory therefore my manifestations about the supreme will were necessary
for the decency that be fitted it let me say something there very simply the lord has to create
his own space in us to be able to reign in us because when he comes into us as i said before
we're a big mess and he's got to make a space for himself he's got to keep on increasing this space
and he calls that conquering a soul correctly because he's conquering the human will and then
finally he'll be able to deposit in that soul the divine will and that it will be safe it won't be
in danger now you must know that my will is greater and more endless than redemption itself this was
the query that luisa had and what is greater always brings greater fruits and goods my will is eternal
in time and in eternity watch this now it had no beginning and it will never end
on the other hand though being eternal in the divine mind redemption had its beginning in time
it was a product of the eternal will so it was not redemption that gave life to the divine will
it was the divine will that gave life to redemption in other words the divine will is supreme over
everything and whatever has the power to give life by nature and by necessity must become more
fruitful than the one who actually received life okay so this is not all jesus said in creation
the divinity issued from itself the shadows of its light this is wonderful because i've just
been saying that the divine will journey is a journey with real steps in it and real surrenders
and real challenges and all the rest of it and what jesus is going to say here is that if you go
back to the very beginning of creation his light only increased slowly over the millennia i mean
that's fantastic in creation the divinity issued from itself the shadows of its light the shadows
of its wisdom and the shadows of its power it touched the whole of creation lightly with its
whole being like this fantastic here you've only got the beginning of the manifestation of god
who is light so the beauty the harmony the order the love the goodness of god which can be seen in
the whole of creation are divine similes their shadows of the supreme majesty on the other hand
my will which is not a simile or a shadow it came into the field of creation as the life of all
creation things now creation itself is only a shadow of what god is like but when the divine
will enters into creation that is the reality that is the life the divine will entered into the
field of creation as the life of all creation things and so it is the life it is the foundation
it is the support it is the vivification and it is the preservation of everything that came out of
our creative hands therefore everything is owed to the supreme will my redemption itself bends its
knees before the divine will to implore that it should constitute itself the life of each act
heartbeat and suffering of mine and even of my breathing so as to let vital aids flow within the
creatures in order to save them so jesus is saying it was the divine will in him that was bringing
everything about it was the divine will in creation that made everything alive and fruitful and all
the rest of it is the divine will in us that makes us alive and fruitful and all the rest of it my
redemption he said can be called the tree that's the tree of life john 15 i am divine it can be called
the tree whose root is the divine will that's why jesus said that the true vine would produce the
actual fruit that the father wanted because the divine will was jesus as well and since it has
produced the trunk the branches the leaves the flowers and the goods which are present in the
church it must therefore produce the fruit of life that's all john 15 now which the root of this tree
contains moreover the creation came out from ourselves with the only purpose that our will be
known and loved more than life itself and therefore our will constituted itself the life of everything
so as to be fulfilled as jesus said in john 14 6 i am the way i am the truth i am the life
and jesus is saying here is the divine will that is the life of everything all the other things created
by us and even redemption itself were given as aids in order to facilitate our purpose
so if we do not obtain our primary purpose how can we obtain our complete glory and how can the
creature receive the good established by us furthermore creation that we associate with the father
redemption that we associate with the son and the fiat voluntas tua on earth as it is in heaven
as they work with the holy spirit symbolizes the holy trinity in fact just as the divine persons
are inseparable from one another so these works are also inseparable from one another
naturally because they're coming from the same blessed trinity each one gives the hand to the
other each one helps the other the triumph and the glory belonged to all three of them and since our
will has held the primary place in all of our works creation and redemption remain eclipsed
and is though dissolved within the immensity and endlessness of the supreme will so all of them
are the works of the supreme will what you are looking at absolutely in all three fiats is the
divine will expressing itself in all its wonder and since our will has held primary place in all
our works both creation and redemption remain eclipsed there but you don't see them and as though
dissolved there but you don't see them within the immensity and the endlessness of the divine will
our will envelops everything and keeps the very things done by us as it's thrown from which it rains
and dominates so if our will is everything why are you surprised that it will produce greater
fruits than our other works because Jesus had told us in john 14 12 that his disciples would
produce greater works than he did and those greater works are in the divine will and man will receive
that life which he has but does not know because he keeps it as though compressed drowned weakened
while the divine will moans in size because it wants to carry out its life but it's not allowed
to do so so you see that the problem again is underlined here at the end of this paragraph
and why it is that the divine will has to come in and make space for itself and conquer the human
will and ask us to let things go so that he can have more space and therefore he gives us more
capacity to receive him and so on and so on therefore be attentive because the knowledge of my will
will shake man and will be like cement on the woodworm which original sin produced in the tree of the
human generations now cement on woodworm is going to fill in all the spaces and strengthen the thing
okay so it's going to make up for all the weaknesses so that once the root has been strengthened
the creature allow that life which she had rejected with so much ingratitude allow it to live within
herself so there we have the divine will telling us that he needs to come in make a space for himself
get rid of the junk that we have presented there to him for all the time that we are alive and
create a greater capacity in us so that he can eventually deposit the divine will
safely inside of our being so we leave it there for tonight and thank you for coming